[Music]
whatever nagging doubts there are
the next step has been taken that even
my grandfather now he's got both
vaccines but he's still quite cautious
like he doesn't really
he's a little bit anxious about having a
hug and you know but he's very excited
about the pubs being open
very excited you don't know what other
variants may
may come to the surface so there's no
way of knowing but just got to
take it as it comes don't you i suppose
but people have been hugging for the
last couple of weeks and
this is more or less saying kicking now
you can cook
families and everything and get on with
family's family life as normal
tony only lives a few doors away from
his grandson rue
but for most of this two-year-old's life
they've just not been able to do this
just a hug and a kiss it gets you
through it
he gets you through it losing me sister
he got me through it this little lad
he's just
got his own magic you know whatever
sadness you've had no whatever joys
you've had
it's all gone it's just start again now
just start again
yeah put the tomatoes back this is a day
for the quiet majority
for the people who haven't just given up
or decided to do whatever they want
it is the majority who have got us to
this point
and many of them have made the sacrifice
of their lives
many more students are now back on
campus but some believe that may the
17th
is just far too late usually we will
interact with people in lectures and
have tutorials and you know meet at
coffee shops and stuff but haven't been
able to do any of it so it's been a bit
sort of like the only interaction we're
getting
is over teams and zoom i've been at home
like in my hometown since
december i've just come back to reading
like two weeks ago
so it's been really hard like trying to
do online learning just from my bedroom
but i'm hard to keep motivated and
everything
audiences are back too all these spaces
have sat idling cardiff for far too long
i've introduced a couple of films
already today and i had a bit of a cry i
must admit
um it was um yeah i got very emotional
when i started talking to people so it
was a really um
it was just a lovely feeling like kind
of like seeing people so happy to be
back
while life has been on hold births
deaths and celebrations
have all been muted say happy birthday
from
us and thank you so much until today
i've been out quite a lot sitting in the
garden so i've kind of been literally
taking hand warmers with me
loads of layers scarfs everything so
it's nice to be able to sit in a t-shirt
inside not worry about the weather as
well yeah i think it's the same here i
mean a lot of people have had birthdays
i've had a birthday as well and again
a bit sat in the garden like packing
like you're going for a sleepover
bringing blankets and everything like
gloves and hand warmers and sitting
there so it's definitely much nicer to
be indoors finally
it will take time to readjust to all
this and however many bumps may lurk in
the roadmap ahead
we are slowly moving towards freedom
tom parmenter sky news